When you work for the SCP Foundation, you
need to be ready for anything.
That’s why, as part of the elite Foundation
training regimen, senior researchers and guards
are always running tests, even against things
that aren’t recorded anomalies under the
auspices of the Foundation.
That’s why, today, for a real change of
pace here at SCP Explained, we’re not talking
about the SCP Foundation; we’re talking
about made-up monster stories crowdsourced
over the Internet.
We’re seeing how the Foundation might fare
against iconic Creepypasta monsters and maniacs
like Herobrine, Jeff the Killer, the Slenderman,
Eyeless Jack, Smile Dog, and many more.
We’ve even created all new Mobile Task Forces
to take each one down.
So, could any of them best the Foundation’s
best and brightest?
Let’s take a look and find out.
And be sure to tell us which is your favorite
Creepypasta entity down in the comments below.
Let’s get creepy!
Jeff the Killer First up, we’ve got everyone’s
favorite disfigured, knife-wielding homicidal
teenager.
Whether it’s his terrifying visage or the
iconic “Go to sleep” catchphrase that’s
forever carved into your mind,
there are probably a lot of people out there
who have lost nights of sleep worrying that
this pale-faced monster could be crawling
through their window.
But we know what you’re probably wondering
- isn’t Jeff just a serial killer?
Why would the SCP Foundation use up its time
chasing down any old regular human murderer?
We’d ask for you to think again.
Jeff has displayed feats that clearly mark
him as anomalous:
Despite suffering debilitating burns to his
face and body, he still shows superhuman strength,
agility, and durability.
He’s also able to see without eyelids, suggesting
some supernatural element is at play.
Victims have also reported him dodging shotgun
blasts while stalking prey.
So, how would the Foundation catch him?
Seeing as Jeff’s modus operandi is breaking
into the homes of his victims while they sleep,
the best method would be staking out a neighborhood
where he’s been shown to be active,
keeping close observations on houses, and
even setting up personnel from Mobile Task
Force Sigma-9, “My Name-A Jeff”,
in vacant houses as honey traps.
Jeff is undeniably strong, fast, and tough,
but if attacked
and surrounded by operatives with superior
tactics, he could be subdued without casualties.
Then, it would just be a matter of transferring
him to a standard high-security humanoid containment
cell.
Speaking of horrifying creatures that come
to you in the dead of night…
The Rake
This supernatural entity has been around for
almost a thousand years, as far as scattered
reports are aware.
It’s also been reported across four continents
and a huge number of locations within those
continents - though most recently, it’s
been reported in rural New York State and
Idaho in the early 2000s.
The Rake is an inhuman beast most often known
for its large, frightening eyes and its long,
Rake-like claws.
Not only does the monster feed on human beings,
but it also produces a traumatic level of
fear in its victims.
Thankfully, an entity like this is far more
familiar territory for the SCP Foundation.
Using their state-of-the-art webcrawler software,
they could catalog reported sightings as they
happen and use clusters of these sightings
to triangulate the location of the Rake and
dispatch field agents to perform reconnaissance
missions.
From there, it would just be a matter of waiting
to strike and sending in Mobile Task Force
Zeta-13, “Rake Steppers”, fitted with
Dr. Dan’s SCRAMBLE goggles to prevent them
from being affected by the seemingly cognitohazardous
effects of viewing The Rake.
When the creature is placed in containment
and kept in a state of perpetual bright light,
it would simply be a matter of applying a
Scranton Reality Anchor to prevent the creature
from somehow phasing out of containment.
Just make sure you avoid its big, starting
eyes in the meantime.
Though that won’t be a problem with the
next Creepypasta monster…
Eyeless Jack
This stealthy creature has its no eyes on
one thing and one thing only: Your kidneys.
And unless you want to die or spend the rest
of your life on a dialysis machine, we recommend
you keep your distance from him.
He’s discrete, devious, and diabolical,
and if you wake up in the middle of the night
to see him staring down at you, it may be
the last time your body is able to filter
toxins out of its blood naturally.
Thankfully, we have a way to make the Foundation
put a stop to his organ-harvesting ways.
Sometimes, to catch a Jack, you need to use
a Jack.
There’s no way to catch Eyeless Jack without
delicious, live kidney bait, so we’d recommend
sending in someone who has kidneys to spare:
Dr. Jack Bright.
Bright could be the perfect bait without losing
his life, luring Eyeless Jack into a decoy
house while Mobile Task Force Gamma-391, “Hit
The Road, Jack”, prepares to spring their
cunning trap and plunge this unpleasant kidney-muncher
into a humanoid containment cell forever.
But our next Creepypasta entity doesn’t
want your kidneys.
It wants your life.
Smile Dog
Our next entity seems like a harmless little
jPeg to the untrained eye - a little freaky,
sure, but nothing to lose your mind over.
But we know that there’s far more to this
grinning husky than meets the eye.
If some reports are to be believed, this image
may even be connected to the devil himself.
If you’re unlucky enough to see this image
in the world, it may already be too late for
you.
Those who see it - typically as an email attachment
from a mysterious address - spend the last
week of their life in a hell of the mind before
eventually succumbing to a bleak and mysterious
death.
It’s a classic cognitohazardous image.
And the most frightening part is that it’s
self-propagating, with one of the only ways
to even mildly alleviate the effects seeming
to be “spreading the word”, by subjecting
another person to this nightmare.
That’s when we bring in Mobile Task Force
Rho-19, “Naughty Dog”, an elite group
of hardened military programmers hand-picked
from the CIA’s cyber warfare unit.
They use their very particular set of skills
to design webcrawler software that roots out
and takes down Smile Dog images across the
web, and, hopefully, one day, find the origin
of this whole thing.
The next creature, on the other hand?
We’ve given up on finding the origin of
that.
The Expressionless
This entity kind of looks like a terrifying
store window mannequin, except rather than
modeling fast fashion, she prefers to swallow
cats whole and murder hospital staff.
Oh, and she also calls herself God.
Isn’t she just so quirky?
Her primary abilities seem to be extreme strength
and large, sharp teeth that easily rend through
human flesh.
Thankfully, not anything the SCP Foundation
hasn’t dealt with countless times before.
Seeing as the only recorded incident involving
The Expressionless took place at a hospital
in Los Angeles, that would be the most sensible
area to stake out.
A detail from the creature’s original encounter
is also telling: It reacted severely to the
doctor’s attempts to sedate it, implying
that chemical sedation is an effective method
of incapacitating the beast.
That’s why every member of Mobile Task Force
Kappa-99, “Ain’t No Dummy”, is a sharpshooter
with a tranquilizer rifle capable of putting
a hippo to sleep with a single shot.
She’ll probably feel less like a God in
her containment cell.
But while this monster is Expressionless,
the next has one very notable expression…
Mr. Widemouth
Compared to some of our other Creepypasta
contenders, Mr. Widemouth may not look like
much - but that, our dear friends, is exactly
what this nasty little malefactor wants you
to think.
He may look like Gizmo’s slightly demented
cousin, but his intentions are even more sinister
than that of your average Gremlin.
If you’re a kid home on a sick day, Mr.
Widemouth might strike up a conversation.
After gaining your trust, he’ll try to lure
you to his special place beyond the trees
for some fun.
But take it from us, all you’ll find out
there is your doom.
This crafty little creep’s small stature
and manipulative stealth abilities might pose
somewhat of a challenge for the SCP Foundation,
but that doesn’t mean they can’t get him
with a little intelligence and elbow grease.
Mobile Task Force Alpha-18, “The Smile Smashers”,
will follow reports of children disappearing
from their isolated homes under mysterious
circumstances.
Then, using an extra-strength butterfly net
straight from the folks at Foundation R and
D, they can chase down and capture the nasty
little monster.
But that won’t be the case for this next
demonic offering.
No, this creepypasta legend is the one that
captures you…
NoEnd House
In recent years, there’s been a spike in
interest in so-called “extreme” haunted
houses.
If you’re not sure what these places are
like, basically picture a CIA black site with
the occasional plastic skeleton - it’s all
waterboarding, stress positions, and car batteries.
But even those places are nothing compared
to the nightmare of NoEnd House - it’s a
moving, possibly even sentient spatial anomaly
hiding in a haunted house attraction, and
if you find yourself inside, best believe
you’re never going to see the outside ever
again.
Thankfully, Mobile Task Force Delta-35, “McKamey’s
Bane”, are on the case.
Around Halloween every year, they use webcrawlers
to detect chatter around NoEnd House events,
so they can swoop in and intercept, preventing
hapless thrill-seekers from being devoured
by the house and providing amnestic treatment
for anyone who has too close a call.
Sadly, the Foundation will not be able to
provide refunds for those who already paid.
Speaking of paying, you’ll really pay if
you even up in our next creepypasta location
of doom…
Abandoned By Disney
Mowgli’s Kingdom, an abandoned tropical
Disney attraction based on the Jungle Book
Movie, is abandoned for a reason.
It’s a hotbed for anomalous activity, including
freakishly large mutant snakes, reports of
ghostly activity, and most prominent of all,
a terrifying photonegative Mickey Mouse that
stalks any hapless urban explorers who happen
to find their way onto the site.
Of course, the Walt Disney Corporation keeps
it all hush-hush, and the SCP Foundation is
happy to give them a hand on that front.
Even if the frightening photonegative Mickey
was removed from the site, it’s likely that
another may appear and continue haunting the
site.
And seeing that the site cannot be moved as
a whole, the Foundation’s best bet is to
form a perimeter around the abandoned Disney
attraction, preventing anything normal from
getting in and anything abnormal from getting
out.
Mobile Task Force Omega-17, “Sons of Shere
Khan”, are ever vigilant and maintain a
strong presence in the surrounding area.
But you don’t need to go anywhere for this
next anomalous terror.
If you’re a big Nintendo fan, it might be
sitting in your house right now…
BEN Drowned
This haunted NES cartridge of The Legend of
Zelda: Majora’s Mask contains the restless
spirit of its last owner, a guy named Ben,
who...
Well, Drowned.
If you slot this creepy little gaming experience
into your Nintendo Entertainment System, you’ll
soon find that the soul of Ben is communicating
with you directly, telling you about how he
died and why his consciousness lingers on,
embedded in the code of the game.
Thankfully, other than the psychological trauma
of experiencing the game, you’re unlikely
to be actually harmed by playing it.
However, Mobile Task Force Beta-51, “Gamers
Don’t Have Rights”, are still on the case.
They try to intercept all cursed copies of
the game and administer amnestics to anyone
who was unfortunate enough to play it.
While it’s still undeniably spooky, it does
feel like a relief to finally find a safe-class
anomaly on this list.
The same can, sadly, not be said about our
next creature…
The Goatman
If you’re a fan of camping, then this malicious
mimic is going to be your worst nightmare.
This monster has existed as a fixture of terror
in everything from a number of Native American
mythologies to iconic 4Chan greentext posts.
You may be thinking, “What’s so scary
about a goat?”
But this thing is no goat - aside from the
fact it’s the Greatest Of All Time at getting
you to crap your cargo shorts in the woods.
First, you’ll smell blood in the air, and
then feel an odd electrical static, like the
feeling all around you right before a lightning
strike.
Then you’ll hear strange noises.
Something not quite like a voice, like an
animal throat straining to form human words.
That’s when you might notice your group
of friends has one more person than you remembered.
And the one thing worse than noticing that
is not noticing it, because if you don’t,
you may end up as the shape-shifting Goatman’s
latest victim.
Mobile Task Force Theta-11, “Got Your Goat”,
are constantly on the hunt for this one, but
its extreme intelligence and ethereal nature
make it a nightmare to track.
But forget nightmares to track, it’s time
for…
Laughing Jack
This candy-striped clown from hell is a really
nasty customer.
Definitely do not engage unless you’re got
a Scranton Reality Anchor on hand, and you’ve
got backup from members of Mobile Task Force
Iota-40, “Put Jack In The Box.”
As a former imaginary friend gone rogue, Laughing
Jack is a semi-intangible Reality Warper of
considerable power.
He targets his victims with sadistic glee,
pulling them into his dark carnival to experience
all kinds of nasty tortures.
Laughing Jack shows no remorse, giggling while
committing every evil act you can imagine.
You’ll probably only find this clown funny
if you’re already a depraved serial killer,
and his sense of humor is likely to utterly
break your mind unless you’ve been given
amnestic treatment from the SCP Foundation.
This is an anomaly that would probably get
along swimmingly with SCP-106, the Old Man.
They could chat over a few drinks one evening
and share notes on how to cause the maximum
pain to their hapless victims.
That being said, few people understand maximum
pan more than the next horrifying abomination
on our roster…
The Russian Sleep Experiment Test Subjects
As anyone familiar with the work of the GRU
Division-P will tell you, the Soviets performed
some pretty horrific occult activities throughout
the 20th Century.
One of the most disturbing of these was the
infamous Russian Sleep Experiment, wherein
a group of unfortunate political prisoners
were dosed on a classified anomalous gas that
robbed them of their ability to sleep - a
chemical compound that the scientists hoped
might increase the productivity of their workers
and soldiers by eliminating sleep.
Instead, over several terrifying days, the
chemical and the sleep deprivation that ensued
caused the subject to instead become demonic
monsters.
While current accounts of the story suggest
that all the subjects were killed, we can’t
say for sure there weren’t more out there
or that the experiment hasn’t been repeated.
As such, Mobile Task Force Omicron-8, “Nighty
Night”, is constantly on the lookout for
freakish, skeletal men wandering through the
woods, never sleeping, outside the dark forests
where Siberian gulags used to be based.
Better safe than sorry, right
Though, of course, you won’t feel safe at
all if you spent your childhood watching scary
media.
Like horror movies, or eerie SCP YouTube channels
-like and subscribe, by the way - or scariest
of all, a strange little puppet show called…
Candle Cove
Feel a little chill go down your spine?
Oh yes, you remember this show, don’t you?
You loved seeing all those cute little puppets
going on swashbuckling pirate journeys on
their adorable boat, the Laughing Stock.
Though there was always that villain, wasn’t
there?
You think his name was Jawbone.
But that’s not what you called him: You
called him the Skin Taker, because he always
had that long cloak made of tanned human skin.
You also remember that one episode that was
just all the characters screaming.
I mean, how could you possibly forget?
And most of all, you remember asking your
mom about it, and her telling you that you
never actually watched a show called Candle
Cove - You just sat around watching static
for hours on end.
Of course, the SCP Foundation keeps close
tabs on everything related to this traumatic
childhood memory.
Mobile Task Force Xi-30, “Childhood Ruiners”,
use webcrawlers to detect forum discussions
of Candle Cove.
Broadcasts of the show are seemingly impossible
to contain - All the Foundation can really
do is track down people who have seen it and
provide amnestic treatment.
Though trust us, there are things that will
make your childhood far worse than just watching
Candle Cove.
Like running into this next iconic monster…
The Slenderman
This terrifying entity is powerful as he is
iconic.
A shapeshifting, faceless, tentacled nightmare
in a three-piece suit who likes to hide in
forests and abandoned buildings, either stealing
children away or influencing their minds until
they become his “Proxies” - supernatural
servants who do anything their inhuman master
asks them to.
The Slenderman is one of the most powerful
monsters in all of Creepypasta, so their Foundation
certainly has their hands full with keeping
his tentacles under wraps.
All that Mobile Task Force Chi-90, “Marble
Hornets”, can do is track sightings and
keep children out of the woods when the danger
of potential Slenderman encounters arising.
Getting him actually contained basically seems
out of the question.
Phew, after all this, we might need to relax.
Maybe grabbing a nice, sugar-free soda and
playing a session of Minecraft might make
us feel better.
We’ll be safe there, right?
Well, probably, unless we encounter…
Herobrine
The SCP Foundation, funnily enough, is actually
no stranger to anomalies trapped in Minecraft
- they’ve got SCP-4335 - A Welt In The Crucible
- to thank for that.
But this Minecraft horror story is a little
more...
personal.
Herobrine is a mysterious user with the Minecraft
default skin, except with one difference:
Completely white eyes.
This mysterious figure invades different Minecraft
servers, acting incredibly strange towards
the people who created them.
What makes this more than just some random
troll?
Well, according to legends, Herobrine is the
manifestation of the dead brother of Minecraft’s
creator, Notch.
Naturally, the Foundation doesn’t want people
running into ghosts on Minecraft, so they
dispatch Mobile Task Force Chi-69, “Blocked
and Reported”, to quarantine any servers
where Herobrine is sighted, and spread misinformation
that the crafty little entity had never actually
existed in the first place.
What is the truth of the situation?
It’s unclear, and that’s exactly how the
Foundation likes it.
So there we have it, folks, how the SCP Foundation
would counteract some of the most infamous
Creepypasta creeps and creatures out there.
Which was your favorite?
Did we miss any of your favorites?
And would you like to see any of these expanded
into a full video in future?
Let us know down in the comments...
If you dare.
Now go check out “SCP Minecraft World Destroyer
SCP-4335 - A Welt In The Crucible” and “SCP
Edition - Weirdest Things on Amazon - Dr Bright's
Great Idea!”
for more bizarre, unexpected anomalous crossovers!